It goes without saying that the SCP Foundation
archives are filled with some terrifying monsters.
Even the deadliest creatures can, in theory,
be defeated, or at least soundly avoided.
After all, they’re just flesh and blood
- or in some cases, metal or concrete.
But what if reality as you know it one day
just…broke.
Or worse, you were transported to a reality
so frightening and alien to our own that death
seemed like the only escape – but you couldn’t
even give yourself that.
This brings us to today’s topic – the
terrifying alternate reality of SCP – 3001.
The Foundation is no stranger to freaky alternate
dimensions, but what was experienced by joint-lead
researcher Dr. Robert Scranton at Site 120
is a truly unique nightmare.
Co-managed by his wife, Dr. Anna Lang, Site
120 is a facility largely designed for research
into SCPs with dangerous reality-warping capabilities
in order to mitigate future containment breaches.
Reality warpers are among some of the more
perplexing and dangerous SCPs, from the pocket
dimension-creating SCP – 106 to the SCP-creating
Doctor Wondertainment, and everything in between.
Scranton and Lang’s goal to further study
such entities was an admirable one, if a little
over-ambitious, and on January 2nd, 2000,
during the testing of a new technology created
by the Foundation’s leading power couple,
disaster finally struck.
Scranton and Lang had already been the brains
behind one of the Foundation’s most valuable
tools in the fight against reality-bending
SCPs: The Scranton Reality Anchors.
Their follow up, the Lang-Scranton Stabilizer
– or LSS – likely would have been an even
more advanced variant of their earlier invention
and should have been a huge success for the
team.
But things didn’t turn out that way…
Dr. Scranton and several other researchers
were gathered in Reality Lab A performing
routine tests on the LSS prototypes.
While other technicians ran diagnostics tests,
Scranton stood at the control panel, the blinking
red light above the console confirming that
everything was going according to plan.
But as anyone who’s fallen victim to one
of the Foundation’s many anomalies will
tell you, just because you’ve done everything
correctly doesn’t mean you’re safe.
Scranton began operating the machine, not
knowing that something was rumbling up towards
him from below.
Without warning, a sudden, unexpected burst
of seismic activity rocked the entire base.
Researchers grabbed onto whatever was closest
as the world shook around them.
In his panic, Dr. Scranton clung to the LSS
control panel as the seismic blast fried the
circuits and kicked it into overdrive.
There was a blast of magnificent, blinding
light, and when the rumbling stopped not only
was the doctor gone, he had been erased from
reality as we know it.
The earthquake had caused a deadly malfunction
in the machine meant to stabilize reality,
and instead tore a rift in it, dragging the
unfortunate doctor and the control panel into
oblivion.
His wife, Dr. Lang, and the many researchers
who idolized him were devastated by his unexpected
demise at the hand of what should have been
his crowning achievement.
The one silver lining was that this reality-ripping
event had almost definitely eliminated the
doctor quickly and painlessly.
As far as The Foundation and his loved ones
were concerned, Scranton’s death had been
immediate and complete – a luxury afforded
to few Foundation employees who die anomalous
deaths.
But sadly that isn’t how Dr. Scranton’s
story – or the story of SCP – 3001 – ends.
No, this is where it all begins.
How do we know all this?
In the hellish new place where Scranton had
been transported, the control panel from the
LSS that he’d been clinging to for dear
life had been transported with him, and continued
to record audio data from this anomalous location.
Not that Dr. Scranton realized it, not at
first, anyway.
As far as he knew, he’d suddenly been transported
into a pitch-black location.
No sights, no sounds, no scents.
True nothingness.
At first, the doctor was confused.
One second, he was testing out his new technology,
and the next he was quite literally nowhere.
In spite of his current situation, the doctor
was still an intelligent and rational man.
He took a moment to compose himself, hoping
that in time his eyes would adjust to the
new darkness around him.
But that moment never came: The darkness remained
perfectly absolute.
Much like the darkness in another reality-defying
SCP, the deadly endless staircase known as
SCP – 087, the dark seemed thick, almost
like you could touch it.
The doctor, not wanting to give himself to
despair and die in this impossible place,
and with no other options seemingly available,
began walking.
Either he’d find his way out, or the Foundation
would find him.
No need to panic.
It may have altered the doctor’s temperament
if he knew that the Foundation already assumed
he was dead, and that no search party was
going to come looking for him.
Still, logic dictates that if a person walks
for long enough, they’re bound to find something.
The problem Scranton was about to face was
that SCP – 3001 doesn’t run by any kind
of conventional logic.
He walked and walked and walked, but he didn’t
seem to get any nearer to or farther from
anything but how could even know?
After all, in total darkness, there aren’t
any landmarks to assist in navigation.
The doctor walked and paced and screamed for
days on end, but he made no progress.
He was alone in an empty world.
He had no choice though, so he kept walking,
and walking, and walking.
For eleven days.
During that time, he felt his hunger and thirst
grow.
He was in terrible pain from a mix of starvation
and dehydration, but the release of death
didn’t seem to come for him.
He was going to have to learn the rules of
this new place the hard way, and it grimly
dawned on Dr. Scranton that dying in this
place might not even be the worst possible
outcome.
He paced and repeated facts to himself, hoping
to ground himself in the moment and avoid
the panic that could so easily set in.
“Name, Robert Scranton.
Age, 39.
Birthday, September 19, 1961.
Favorite color, blue.
Favorite song, "Living on a Prayer."
Wife…
Anna…”
Little by little, the words seemed to turn
to nonsense in his mouth as the terror grew.
Just as he felt like he was about to lose
his mind, he noticed something - a small oasis
in the endless darkness of SCP – 3001: The
glowing red light of the LSS control panel.
Where had it come from?
And how was it still recording?
The doctor had no idea, but he was grateful
for any kind of familiarity in the strange
darkness around him.
Perhaps the LSS could be the key to saving
him, or at least figuring out what on earth
was going on here?
Whatever the case, there was no denying that
having the panel here was better than nothing.
At least, when it was found… if it was ever
found, then people would know what had happened
to him.
As the days passed and he continued to mysteriously
survive, Dr Scranton deduced that one didn’t
need food or water to survive continually
in SCP – 3001.
The location had an anomalous effect on its
inhabitants.
As the days passed and turned to weeks of
wandering in the darkness, Dr. Scranton further
deduced that he was no longer in his home
dimension – this was an entirely separate
pocket dimension, much like the one possessed
by SCP – 106, but featureless.
A perfect, self-contained void.
Now dimly illuminated by the red light of
the panel, Dr. Scranton explored further into
the void around him.
He travelled for months on end, the pain of
his deficiencies growing by the day, but found
he was getting nowhere.
All things considered, he wasn’t even sure
he was moving, or whether reality and the
darkness was swirling around him like a thick
liquid.
Rather than walking on a single flat surface,
he was moving in all directions across a three-dimensional
plane.
The space-time continuum appeared to be entirely
broken here, where movement is more defined
by the conscious intention to move than any
real geographical repositioning.
Dr. Scranton knew that this place broke every
single one of Kejel's Laws of Reality Parameters,
and from his years working with a plethora
of reality warpers in Site 120, he had a theory
for why this pocket dimension was so strange:
It had an extraordinarily weak Hume field.
Before we get back to Dr. Scranton’s semi-living
nightmare, we need a quick primer on Hume
theory, and why having a weak Hume field is
such a problem.
A Hume is a unit of measurement for the strength
and amount of reality in a given location
or being.
In an area with an incredibly low Hume field
relative to our world, such as SCP – 3001,
universe breaches and anomalous incidences
rise significantly.
At the time of his being trapped there, SCP
– 3001 had the lowest number of Humes in
any recorded environment, making it a phenomenally
anomalous zone.
It was for this reason that starvation and
dehydration never took hold of him despite
causing him great pain, and the worst by far
was yet to come.
Dr. Scranton wasn’t trapped in this dimension
for weeks or even months.
He was trapped in the darkness for years.
And it took a nightmarish toll on his body
and mind.
The small flashing red light on his LSS control
panel became his only friend and as the years
drew on, he would hold entire conversations
with his only source of illumination.
He knew that his days were numbered – if
he didn’t escape dimension within around
three years, the Hume field would diffuse
further, and he would be left in a truly horrific
state.
But based on how little headway he’d made
in the time he’d been there, he didn’t
feel optimistic.
He kept speaking into the recorder, if only
to break the silence and prevent him from
going completely insane.
But even that would only hold it off for so
long.
Alone and talking to himself endlessly in
the darkness, Dr. Scranton could feel his
mind slipping as the confines of the pocket
dimension constricted and his body began to
change.
The low Hume field slowly diffused his physical
matter, destroying the physical integrity
of his body but never being merciful enough
to actually let him die.
In his haunting audio logs, the doctor described
his hands as diffusing and thinning out like
spider webs.
Over time, there was less and less of him,
and what was left wasn’t entirely human.
As Scranton’s Hume level lowered to equalize
with that of SCP – 3001, the lines between
his body and the LSS control console began
to blur in a twisted marriage of warped flesh
and machine.
The Lang-Scranton Stabilizer was anything
but stable.
Before his mind and body became something
else entirely, the doctor still had the presence
of mind to finally realize how he’d come
to be in this terrible place.
The LSS had opened a wormhole known as a Class-C
“Broken Entry” into a paradoxical pocket
dimension between layers of reality, and taken
him through it.
He’d slipped through a crack in reality
into absolute darkness, and now he was stuck
with a fate far worse than death.
How do we know any of this?
Much like the event in the first place, it’s
a total accident.
Testing superior reality-bending technology
almost six years after the disappearance caused
the sudden return of the missing LSS to Site
120’s Reality Labs.
The only trace of Dr. Scranton that it brought
back with it was the blood and viscera that
coated the console, much to the abject horror
of his still grieving wife, Dr. Anna Lang.
To this day, Dr. Scranton, formerly one of
the Foundation’s brightest minds, remains
trapped in the nightmare of SCP – 3001.
His current condition whether the doctor is
still alive after twenty years of being warped
by the low Hume field of 3001’s darkened
confines is still unknown.
But, for the doctor’s own sake, we hope
he’s been dead for quite some time, because
few things on earth are as horrifying as the
alternative…